I had no idea that the Abbey Road studio  section of my career was going to come  so quickly but know that we're here to  feel like I'm never gonna go back when I  was first asked to sing this song during  the commercial I was like really excited  and then when I listened to the track I  realized it's probably one of the  hardest songs to sing  [Music]  I don't care what they're going to say  let the storm rage  the cold never bothered me anyway I  thought that this campaign was really  fun  and I thought it had a really good  message for a big company like Aldi  there's like such a huge set that whole  idea of letting go of the past and like  the new future holds a lot of hope  I think advertising it's nice when it  uplifts you  [Music]  do it again  that was me being an evil run the truck  [Music]  thanks guys what fun thank you very much  thank you  [Music]